you lost somebody really brilliant and
funny in the comedy community and I know
I'm talking about Brody Stephens and you
were very close with Brody and had
worked with Brody everybody in the
comedy world was a fan of Brody Stephens
really brilliant comic and so his and
his passing was very tragic yeah he was
so funny he really was a comedians
comedian and he was one of the few
people that every single comedian loved
it would run in the room to see and you
know years ago I did this movie funny
people and I shot all these comedians
and I didn't know if I would use any of
it in the movie but every time Adam
Sandler would do stand-up I would shoot
a lot of other people and one night I
shot Brody's act and it didn't wind up
in the movie but then he kept talking
about it all the time yes he talked
about it incessantly it became his
shtick kind of he would go on and on
about all the things that had worked out
for him and then he would say cut from
funny people I was cut out of funny
people and he would say it all the time
and so last week I went through all the
footage to find the footage of Brody in
funny people and I found it and it's
beautiful was shot by Janusz Kaminski
the great cinematographer I did like
Lincoln and I wanted to show everybody
this a little bit of the great Brody
Stephens this is really sweet let's take
a look right now at the work of Brody
Stephens come on please I got pinked on
my sister beat me up she punched me she
kicked me she spit on me she threw keys
at me and the beatings with the keys
hurt the most why you asked because my
sister was a janitor she had a lot of
keys please stop it were your parents
divorced because of you no I was in
trouble in I used to break toys I was
aggressive very hairy I shaved when they
mocked 11:00
it sucks I went for a swim out in Venice
Beach and I clogged the drain they shut
it down my hair is worse than a hyper
d'emic needle hyper demon a new word yes
I'm confident I
it rents very expensive currently I live
in the gay section of Compton and the
Shirley Hemphill house for young
starving artists it's great you know a
lot of people think Brodie you do well
you must be a part of the mile-high club
that's having sex in the airplane I am
NOT a part of the mile-high club
however one time I jerked off on a
ferris wheel LA County Fair during the
Sugar Ray concert and it's tough I'm
from Reseda they had gangs man karate
kid' I'll take you to me AQIS apartment
on Saticoy I'll take you to the Banzai
area where he fought sad tough hop in
the fence that's my life please fearless
absolutely he would pick out people in
the crowd that weren't laughing yeah he
would do something that no comic that he
would find people in the crowd that
weren't laughing and go at them in the
most hysterical way yeah yeah such a
fantastic it couldn't be funnier we're
all devastated I'm going to miss him a
ton